va a
[Risate]
marco bianchi o no guarda chi c'è qua
dentro e non ci sono soci entriamo in un
nuovissimo ascensore e pauroso ma anche
un futuro non lo incontreremo vari
personaggi di ancora tempo oggi siamo
vestiti molto simili di tutto il
personaggio per la mia maglietta e
funerailles la mia rosa ragione ma vabbè
abbiniamo bambini aldo perini oggi
facciamo bene si può abbinare in più il
taglio di capelli che somiglia di più al
mio taglio reale di capelli invece
evitare ha sempre la lingua fuori perché
ha sempre fame che si è lasciato bene mi
piace meglio di prendere qualcosa da
mangiare una casa da bere iniziamo
subito con il primo piano
ma dove siamo e dove sei non lo so tu
sei tu a forse si entra da qua ecco
perché c'è un ascensore ok vediamo che
li pelliccia su pendano quanti piani ci
aspettano ok siamo già al primo piano di
via
che cos'è quasi tutti abbiamo la porta
giusta aver visto unità e pace un
tritatutto buon luca
ce la stiamo cavando bene finora no mi
hanno tritato
e ora sono la vostra fan di giocatrici
abbiamo trovato un altro
il
prossimo piano vediamo questa
età si corre si corre non lo so perché
si corre così ma dove bisogna andare qui
ma ecco attentati parkour book fino a
stare troppo dobbiamo sbrigarci e
soprattutto non sono ancora annegato
sappiamo solo talento ma mi sono accorto
no no no tali sono morto
no sono anche tu prossimo livello è
quello che quindi
non bisogna saltare sul nero ma sul
retro ok questo è giusto io sono caso
questo tema schetter e saltata su uno di
quelli ok passare lungo e papà ho visto
vitale sfracellarsi
tuffava è difficilissimo questo nuovo
sensore hi di ok ok allora era facile
forza 1 questo primo avanti guardiamo
che dovevano poi questo poi questo io
seguo vitale e poi questo
e poi questo è troppo forte
[Musica]
finalmente abbiamo superato un livello
ma adesso che dobbiamo fare dobbiamo
dobbiamo ritornare indietro no non credo
abbiamo preso il pool aspetta un fatto
485 punti
forse sì forse dobbiamo davvero tornare
indietro
perché abbiamo preso
ok proattivo piano vedi mappa
eccole si sta aprendo cosa che fini
non c'è votare wow
[Musica]
no aspetta aspetta aspetta
prendere la macchina di quella che sta
avanti
ecco allora che ha troppo a un'altra
macchina ho fatto reginette allora sto
trascinando perché non so se questo mare
in quella rabbia ma che
era io ma sono ancora liso riesco ad
andare da una rampa è troppo di papà
sono cadute monito prossimo livello
vediamo una casa abbandonata bello
[Musica]
e mi sono trasformato wow siamo
trasformato in un nuovo non so che cosa
succede no
non tornò più normale sono ancora un
signore io voglio tornare per un po
ma ne verremo in prima dovrò continuare
tutto il gioco come il signore perché
davanti ho capito questo come uomo ve lo
ricordate se avete visto andate a
vederlo perché troppo divertente allora
cerchiamo di scappare perché qui il topo
non ci lascerà scampo ho trovato un
pezzo di formaggio gigante brera ai
presunti acque di punti probabilmente
così non va dove dopo
aiuto che non e vicolo cieco forma
perché io devo essere questo signore ha
sin qui trovi un pezzo di formaggio
gigante forse no ero io quello ma non
c'è niente ok ma per fortuna non abbiamo
incontrato il topo che succede o no che
cosa facessero noti sono di aiuti strana
le palle di capire se un livello pauroso
[Musica]
marchi
davis ma non so se sarà sempre vivo io
ce l'ho portato i biscotti il discorso
bisogna evitare va a prendere i biscotti
non sono biscotti sono cupcake perfetto
ok ragazzi abbiamo cambiato allora
veramente troppo strano
primo piano vediamo cosa ci aspetta
come posso dire qui dalle scale mettiamo
in una prigione se protesi
cos'era il cattivo a
jason tye renet ma ve lo ricordate quel
poliziotto con la sirena
interrotto le skype room di questo
cattivo sì sì sì sì sì è tornato aiuto e
velocissimo dove la porta dell'ascensore
di scappare dove sei tu io sono al piano
di sopra
e ha fatto fuori un po di giocatori così
dov'è è ancora là dentro l'ascensore io
sono fuori sopravvivere il più tempo
possibile così prendiamo confronti
possibile
chi sta prendendo
aiuto ma quando finisce fatto livello io
sto raccogliendo sacco di monetine
isagro fatta e con chi è qua con noi
nella sua parola come possibili non era
mai successo questo prima che un cattivo
rimanesti dentro l'ascensore
abbiamo portato con noi mi sembra
intrappolati favole uscire ma non ci
riesce
prossimo livello ok settore 1 dove siamo
cos'era un rumore
a capo chi è il cattivo qua
[Musica]
chi veramente big piston e hunter pighi
bianca
no già preso
mannaggia abbiamo perso con troppi
dimora rientriamo e vediamo chi
affronteremo questa volta è come quella
pd lo vedete bravo allora vediamo chi
c'è qua chi è il cattivo quater bloggare
sembra una casa normale
ordinate vivo
il fuoco il camino acceso
sera il carlino qua
aiuto
ehi ma non c'è nessuno che cosa è
successo
[Musica]
ma che bene
io vado a nascondermi dentro l'ascensore
io adori ha pure tu sei scappato a con
sopra e mi dispiace
in ottobre
a proposito di cose paura avete già
preso il mio nuovissimo libro e paura
tra soli rispetto scrivete nei commenti
tu non lo avete preso ancora non potete
non averlo cliccato il link di
iscrizione per esserlo subito
o no guarda chi c'è qua dentro
chi c'è potere anna bello e la bambola
guarda vabbè ognuno dentro
io ti seguo io sono già in ascensore
ciao ma così carina è piccolino eppure
così cattiva
vedete sembra una bambolina carinissima
ma che sono per niente sto prendendo
qualcuno li egli rimane nascosta qua io
sto attaccando mi ha fatto a fette no
c'è un romano c'è una mamma sto bene mi
sto spostando la mano ti prende meno
male ha preso qualcun altro ok hanno
superato i 900 16 punti e tu milo tutto
ciò è un po come tale mi ha superato
esce il prossimo livello vediamo che il
cattivo quando è un parco giochi ha
un'aria familiare questo parco giochi no
non me lo ricorda niente
sento dei rumori di vetri
dov'è il cattivo non vedo nessuno che
pighi bianca no non lo so quelle però
che prima con noi e ci sarà qui eccolo
parolisi come si chiama jack jason
ok scappiamo scappiamo blu metri ma lo
vedo è attento e velocissimo e vicino
alla fontana ma io sono vicino alla
fontana sta raccogliendo della monetina
certo molti
acciacchi grezza di aver capito si si
sono tanta vita
è uscito da una scatola vedove dove mi
sono scoperto lo vedono lo vedo
aiuto visto non l'ho visto ancora sto
cercato di nascondermi qua eccolo
aiuto
che brutto lo vedete la sopra sta
cercando di affrettarci io torno
nell'ascensore mi dispiace ma
anche
giocatore benvenuto
allora mi sembra che sia ancora pupazzo
di wise nessuno l'ha attivato smettila
di seguirmi e chi è che ti sta seguendo
che scritte tranne niente di personale
sia sparito gli uomini
ecco in coda
da
quando vi siete volendo equa nella
fabbrica di giocattoli
da voi fatevi seguire anche voi ok
eccole andato di là il porno o nostra
entrato entrato nella censore
sì effettivamente un po strano che oggi
come pagato tutti nel settore no un paio
ok io salgo quest'opera forse non
riuscirò a prendermi no scherzavo riesce
a saltare sembra una scimmia
priva di symbian vaghi e una scimmia no
non ne andò in questo caso leone figlio
ecco d'italia lì nascosto ce la faccio a
questo punto
non trovato prima possibile
eccoci
lo scavo di cui non ha forse no mi
ricorda qualcosa questo livello ma forse
era jack skeletron oer and tipo
1 con la testa di zucca c'era quali
terna
lo ricordo ma io ero tornato ecco a chi
guardi che scappa anche lui c'è qualcuno
nascosto la famiglia preso ma tu sei
lasciato un
attimo a livello anche dicono mi ricorda
col mondo ma non mi ricorda chi era il
cattivo comuni dell'area 51 mi sa un
alien si vediamo che c'è e non è appreso
chi è questo qui a renderman ha preso
che beh allora quanti punti abbiamo
fatto io 1.134 e tu
1428 avvisami
volete poteva altra parte nella settore
aveva
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
su quella che preferite buona visione